happy Memorial Day everybody I'm a
little intimidated cuz to my right the
first guests that we've had that has
chose to do the left coast a left coast
and Peter King is invading my territory
I don't like to win your thing like
listen to the intro as I Peter so big
I'm like that music that is actually
created by rod Simba who is one of our
listeners who was a music producer
you're good right yeah that's very good
we burn press rot Simba has done a lot
of good work for us free of charge it's
been amazing
Rod's the man him and all his producers
doesn't hit me so first thing I want to
ask Peter King yes we text from time to
time okay when he wants to answer yes he
replies with a meow yeah meow
okay can you be here at 2:10 yeah is
that a Super Trouper okay now that is
the funniest scene in all of television
history
yes history I think so well this is a
splint or is the best movie in history
which Ventura - oh sorry so how dare he
ask you who Ace Ventura is pretty funny
thank you very much you're on the
outside you think it's for the best
movies ever I'm not saying it's one of
the best movie they think it's one of
the funniest scenes at least Super
Troopers just because you know I've
never heard meow heard said so many
different ways and so many like normal
sentences it's also because it's finding
comedy in a traffic stop yeah where
where anyone's pretty darn funny I
almost want the police like to kind of
mess with me what were you speeding meow
yeah they're coming out with a new one -
I think they have a new one out I want
to see it yeah yeah so we're gonna this
is we're recording this on a Wednesday
it's coming out on a Monday because look
you're taking over Monday Morning
Quarterback
quarterback with Peter King yeah is what
you're gonna wake up on Monday and it's
gonna be well you know what I'm gonna
wake up on Monday morning and I'll be in
Paris France Wow you're putting my wife
there for her 60th birthday good for you
what we're Monday's typically like
for you guys during Monday morning
quarter last Sunday night you can Sunday
night's you were just telling us you
were doing what well I live on the Upper
West Side of Manhattan and we were
talking about how how incredibly noisy
it is at all hours of the day or night
in Manhattan and I and so I'll be
writing there at 3:30 in the morning on
Monday and there were just there people
leaning on their horns at the stoplight
in front of my building and I just think
to myself it just never ends in New York
no but Monday's will be about the same
thing I'm gonna do the same thing
basically for NBC that I'm doing for so
beside Upali all-nighters like I mean
where I do I'm up until about I'd say
5:30 normally on on Sunday so I like to
think about this so you're up until 5:30
in the morning on Monday you release
this like opus of like thousands of
words and all these nuggets and then do
you sleep as the rest of the world is
like processing your information I mean
I try to sleep as much as I can but
usually I'm up by about 10:00 so
Twitter's exploding and Peter King is
napping I have to know I just like the
vision you can't stay up you know you
got to go to sleep but I mean I do it a
little bit less and I hope that the
column will consistently be up at NBC
this year we had a consistently up at
the mmq be at 5:00 a.m. yeah and because
look I mean I think at some point it
becomes a little bit defeatist when you
go and go and go because after a while
you just can't really reason properly
you know so I try to be done I'd really
try to be finished by about between 4
and 5 o'clock last season and hopefully
I'll do the same thing this year at NBC
so you're telling me you have so many
things that you're probably chopping
stuff that doesn't even make it or else
it could what happens to those stories
well there are a lot of those I often
will save something for my Wednesday
column gosh but I don't do I'm not gonna
do that now cuz I'm not doing a
Wednesday column and I feel good it'll
feel pretty good look I love what I do
I'm really fortunate to do what I do or
I'm
tremendously fortunate to do what I do
so this isn't about I hate my job
I don't hate my job there's probably
only one thing I sort of hate now okay
what is that sort of hate me out it's
it's that in May June in July you know
you you finish working on the draft and
many times I'll have been at somebody's
draft and I'll be in the draft room and
then like last year with the 49ers you
know Thursday night after the draft you
go and have a few beers Friday night you
might have a couple of beers yeah you
know and then yeah and and so you stay
up with these guys you stay out with
these guys and then then you fly home
and you take a deep breath and you say
oh now we got to populate the site for
the next ten weeks or something sort of
meaningful yeah and I just said man it's
just it's too much for me I mean I had
two brothers who died young hmm and I
mean I'm 60 years old I I mean I love my
job I love my column I love doing that
stuff I'm not crazy about it in May June
and July we get it me and Sims have
realized working together for the last
five seasons that are our time to take
vacation has been changed and changed
and changed at first it was okay right
after the Super Bowl and then it was you
got to be ready for the draft okay we'll
do it I forget to combine coming and
then the draft happens and it's just Oh
TAS have become like a monumental thing
and then I can tell you what's stupid
about that like OTAs and and offseason
practices yes we just yes go ahead
I often I am call it whoa big offseason
I often have made this point about if if
a quarterback doesn't throw at the
combine I said I have never one time in
my life on the night of the draft heard
a general managers say well we didn't
take John Doe cuz he didn't work out at
the combine yeah it doesn't happen it
doesn't matter
yeah people say oh he's not competitive
oh that is a bunch of bullcrap and it's
the exact same thing now with Oh Tom
Brady is missing these practices I mean
so that one so no so it's weird it's
weird it's weird it's weird and it's
very unbraid alike right I can guarantee
you that when when football starts yep
in September if Tom Brady is healthy and
he's 20% less the player this year I
will be utterly shocked he's not yeah
Tom Brady I think is experiencing and I
don't know anything about this because I
have not talked to him but I think Tom
Brady is experiencing what a normal
human being about to turn 41 with three
young kids and the ability to do things
all over the world would experience I
mean I'm gonna go and practice football
in Foxborough instead of going to do all
these things both of my kids my family
in Qatar in China in wherever and it
just seems to me that he says can I
please have a little bit more of a life
than I've had that's how I look at it I
look I do think there's real well I mean
I know there's little issues there I
guess there must be yes there is I mean
yes I mean from everything I know bits
and pieces do I know this story 100% but
it seems like pretty much that Belichick
was pushing on the organization that
maybe this should be Brady's last year
and Garoppolo should be the guy for the
future Brady got wind to that didn't
like it and of course then it was
grapple Oh got traded and all those
things I don't ever get the full story
you know how New England works I know a
few people up there I get little bits
and pieces and that's just the part I've
tried to piece together but I'm with you
too with first of all who's practiced
more than Tom Brady we both know he's
obsessed with the sport yeah he's making
videos about him doing in the offseason
so we know he's obsessed they also have
their in the AFC Championship game every
year you know what that is an extra
month to practice for Tom Brady so he
can throw a slant route and to come back
with his eyes closed and just a few
years ago we saw the players lockout and
what did we see three quarterbacks there
for 5,000 yards so that just tells you
OTAs again are more for the coaches yeah
than anything because I think they're
how do you think the San Diego Chargers
feel about the OTAs right now when
hunter Henry guy who
when when hunter Henry basically now is
lost for the season yeah and look if
you're going to be running around you're
gonna risk injury I'm not blaming
anybody or blaming anything but what I
am saying is that in my opinion you're
asking an awful lot of these players to
be practicing sort of like they'd
practice during the season only not
hitting the game yes can I tell you my
conspiracy theory about the Patriots my
conspiracy theory is that bill went into
crafts office and was like Robert Kraft
I think it's time that we move on from
Brady and we go to grop below and then
Kraft had Brady and and said just so you
know because I love you Tommy Boy we're
gonna move on to Jimmy Garoppolo and
then saw the emotion in his face and
then I think Bella checks been taken out
of this completely here's the reason why
I don't buy a lot of what I've heard
with theories like yeah yeah now what
you said is very interesting and I have
no idea if it's true or not it's not
anything that I've heard enough about to
even report but but what I would say is
Bill Belichick has brought in so many
veterans over the years and he's all
about winning that and I'm not saying
that it's impossible that he would have
said okay Brady it's over we're going
with Garoppolo right in the middle of an
MVP year for Brady which would have
really imploded everything I think great
I just think I think you have to just
let all of this play out you've got to
let Brady keep playing and then we'll
see what happens and and I just look
this is just my fervent belief the
Patriots didn't take a quarterback this
year because after Baker Mayfield they
didn't really like anybody now the
quarterback from you know from LSU is
Matt Cassel reincarnated right they
might be able to get him coached up to
play a little bit but he's probably
nobody's quarterback in the future but
he's nice he's a Jacoby percent player
at least in their eyes so next year I
believe that Josh McDaniels job during
this offseason they fly into Miami on a
Saturday Josh instead of putting his
feet up and
watching the you know Oklahoma Nebraska
game on TV on Saturday night yeah he's
gonna have some video that he'll before
he goes to bed he'll spend the last 90
minutes before he goes to bed watching
whatever that quarterbacks name is at
Missouri oh yeah he is going to be this
is his job now hmm Josh McDaniels job in
2008 finding the next will be to spend
90 minutes every week on getting ready
for the next guy that's my feeling about
how they're gonna operate I love it I
don't doubt that I mean it just at my
experience of being there I'm sure they
already have a few guys yes on their
radar that are circled I ask one more
thing just whatever you want
oh okay I'm just interested because just
to bring back to something you said a
few minutes ago about like coaches now
and you hanging out in the draft and
having a beer and things like that
now now compared to let's just say 1988
right our play honey our player our
coaches were they more willing to have a
drink with you and hang that way I feel
like they were right oh no question all
right so yeah can you just like
elaborate and that nothing I have to use
specific 1984 I covered football for the
first time I covered the Cincinnati
Bengals in training camp in 1984 I lived
it at Wilmington College where the
Bengals training camp was that was the
year where Boomer Esiason was a rookie
Chris Collinsworth was on the team Munoz
Max Montoya they had a Reggie Williams
they had a lot of really good and really
outgoing Ray Horton a lot of really
outgoing players and the one thing I
will never forget that dorm
okay there's whatever 80 or 90 players
in training camp that was the players
dorm I had a room on the bottom floor
with the Cincinnati Enquirer and I had a
phone in my room and every night the guy
for the Cincinnati Post went home but I
stayed so my room was open so I remember
many nights the reason I had a really
good relationship and ended up having
one with Esiason yeah
and with Chris Collinsworth I will
always believe is because I said hey you
want to you
my phone come on in and you know
obviously no cell phones in those days
and there's there's two pay phones and
everything and so so they came by to
talk to whoever girlfriends favor I
don't know and I would just leave the
room and I'd do something else and
they'd be on the phone for an hour or
something like that but here's the one
other thing yeah five doors down the
hall on the right hand side with Sam
Wyche is sweet he lived in an hour a's
room at Wilmington College area and Sam
Wyche was a rookie coach of the Bengals
and he said if you ever need anything
just knock on my door
so meetings would be over at like 9:30
and I'd go knock on his door and I'd say
hey can you explain your offense to me
and it we'd sit there for an hour in ten
minutes until he was too tired to go
anymore and he'd show me film of
everything that they did on offense it
was frigging amazing right so where did
the change why did it change you know
because he does yes in the year 2000 I
always tell people this story in the
year 2000 I went to the NFL Scouting
Combine it's like me John Clayton Rick
Gosselin Len Pascarella there's hardly
anybody there there's maybe 15 to 20
reporters at the NFL Scouting Combine
this the year 2000 this year 1243
credentialed members of the news media
in Indiana so it's a yes yes because
more people are covering yes yes more
than ever and and the trust tree has
been broken because of that I don't hey
you know I would think they would still
want to have beers with somebody like
you but I believe they do yeah it's not
it's not nearly as often as it was and
Chris I'm gonna tell you this is one of
the other things that is really
different about covering football yeah
you know you realize after a while that
if you sort of are close to a guy that
that guy pretty much expects you to only
write good things about okay that start
oh it's been that way for a while but
but and I'll tell you what happens
because if you're a big star either is a
coach or a player and your team is
winning
all the time or you're throwing for five
thousand yards every year you're a great
player you know that there's a lot of
people who are never gonna write
anything bad about you so let's just say
I write something bad about you all of a
sudden because you've got all these
other big people in the media who are
I'm not saying kissing your feet but
we're always writing nice things then
all of a sudden somebody who writes
something that you really don't like all
of a sudden you're marginalized and
you're on the outside and that has
happened I don't want to say a lot but
that's happened 10 or 15 times with me
yeah over the last few years and I can
see it coming I know it's going to
happen I've told some players please
just understand that one day I really
might write something bad about you I
give you a good example Deion Sanders
yeah
okay so Deion Sanders when he signed
with Washington at the end of his career
they gave him a seven million dollar
signing bonus that was a crazy offseason
he got a big contract that was not hold
at all at that time and like their
second game they go to Detroit he screws
up his foot which I think was already
hurt or he's an ankle and so you know I
just wrote basically that and I'm
paraphrasing that's because I don't
remember exactly what it was but Deion
Sanders stole the signing bonus from
from Dan Schneider and Vinny cerrado and
so I went in later that year in Dion and
I requested a chance to talk to Dion
before some game and the PR guy came
back and said Dion said god bless you
but I'll never talk to you for the rest
of my life now we do talk now but after
I mean I knew him so well I wrote this
the other day I know him so well that he
gave me his pseudonym for Road hotels
right and so I would know you wouldn't
call the hotel in those days people
wouldn't have cells so right you just
call the hotel and say hey can you
connect me with yes though right you
know and so and that's how close I was
to him then but what was it John
Thompson I always know where Langford
I just always know this tell me Peter
King I always know that at some point
these things are probably going to blow
up yeah they just are because if you're
being remote
be honest with you readers sometimes you
have to say things that are not very
nice right because you have two
relationships you have a relationship
with the player you have a relationship
with the reader speaking with what is
your relationship with your Twitter
handle are you gonna change it Tessa -
because it's s i underscore peter king
are we gonna go with I don't even know I
got a few can I give you some left Coco
car yeah you don't need NBC in there
you're Peter King someone might have
Peter King I think there is a guy
there's a much um wait Peter Kings out
there yes yeah I think that you need to
put an adjective that you believe in
before Peter King the Honorable Peter
King great Peter come on Peter King meow
as long as you credit sends a love calm
down Peter King meow I don't know what
I'm gonna do I like meow Peter King yeah
so you guys are you're gonna be kind of
on the same rotation or NBC Bravo bolt
I'll give her the same team which that I
mean I enjoy Peter the conversations
even outside of football we've had some
good ones as of late that I have enjoyed
and I won't go there right now but Peter
- he's taking a lot of pressure off me
with my MBC job how come well I used to
be worried okay that was probably I used
to be worried about being on time but
Peter King first show now this is just
tells you how awesome and big-time this
guy is and you got to out Peter King
nobody I doubt him it was on TV just a
couple of minutes later yeah I just walk
on the Merv Griffin walking just a
little I know who Merv Griffin is I
didn't realize that went on and he shows
back in the people just but that was
amazing you're my idol to do that to
Florio the show starts at 7:00 they said
the day before man Peter might be late
for the show and I've got the show on
cuz I'm going let me see the feeders
they're on time and I turn on a few
minutes late I'm just gonna say this
right now yes 6:39 a.m. I was at the
Starbucks on the first floor of 30 rock
what 6:39 that's how long I walk in
there and I walk in there there's only
four people there but there's one person
who's the barista and the ringer of
although I know
and the person in front of me ordered
nine drinks what's touching be loud well
I would leave and well I couldn't
because I was desperate for I was gonna
write your coffee nerdness column yeah I
need anyway yeah I can't do that anymore
please do it more that was the best that
was awesome he can't do anything to you
so I should do seven oh eight and seven
oh eight baseball game started at seven
eleven that's when you start one
baseball team actually start at seven
eleven they sold White Sox because they
sold it to 7/11 yeah yeah marketing
funny I didn't know that it's good to
know I did hey can I just say one other
you can say whatever you want we're
gonna continue to ask you questions
until you tell us they're so good oh no
okay you just say one more thing so
today now that this is appearing on
Monday yeah so as we record this we're
recording it on the previous Wednesday
yeah so I left home and I'm finishing up
today mm-hmm my favorite stories that
I've done in 29 years at si and it's
really really been interesting to go
back and look at a bunch of the old
things like something I haven't thought
about in a long time is I took a bus in
1990 I took a bus across country with
John Madden it was awesome it was
awesome like we stopped on the side of
the road one time and he pulls a opens a
drawer and he pulls out a book
wildflowers across America what and he
goes look at those things there were
bright red flowers we were on the side
of the road in Kearney Nebraska and it
was like I worked in Hastings Nebraska
40 minutes from Kearney Nebraska right
on a flat there's nothing there Wow
that's right but it was it was great and
the other thing about Nebraska is right
along the side of i-80 not far from
Kearney and not for everyone where we
saw those flowers some guy has a farm
where he invents animals where he
crossbreeds animals and they're just
standing out there like the llama horse
and I mean just the weirdest things
going on at that thing and but anyway so
he was madden was awesome he was so
she's left in the bus that's him and so
he had his bed man he has Madden had the
back third of the bus right he had a
queen-size bed the room it looked like a
a miniature Hyatt suite yes it was
beautiful and he also had in those days
he had a TV in there and he had all the
tapes that week I think he was doing
Giants in Dallas so he had all their
games right there any and so he was just
gonna watch him and that's how he that's
how he fell asleep did he drive the bus
no who drove two drivers okay Dave Hahn
and Willi Yarborough Dave one of them
has died I forget which one but they
were and they they would have shifts and
then they had a little bunk in the
middle of yes and it was great we but
what about hi guys I am going through
all of my stories right now and seeing
all these things and seeing you know
being at Favre's house to 11:30 at night
in the week and the life of the Packer I
saw you write about that a little bit
yeah and and then not knowing that he
was addicted to drugs at the time
knowing it all right and then after that
season that was an amazing thing that
happened after that season with with him
basically going into rehab for the
second as it turns out I didn't even
know this yeah that he had been to rehab
two years before for that for the pillar
for pills my then he went into rehab
again and then the third time he went in
for alcohol because that became like
after he stopped doing the pills then he
really was into alcohol the most amazing
thing about that whole time doing that
as I look back on it now is that I only
wrote 4200 words I spent a week in sigh
min I'm in with Holmgren as he's doing
the game plan I'm in with Steve Mariucci
is anti Detmer as far as farting and
falling asleep in the quarter it was
really great right and so I said 4200
words man I can't even
I write travel notes that are forty two
hundred words long now and and so that's
what has changed and that's one of the
reasons why I have
grown to love the internet because there
isn't a limit if you've got a great
story and the last thing I'll say I keep
going I love that stuff the last thing
I'll say cuz you'll get a great kick out
of this I'm gonna have like maybe 15 or
18 stories with a little writing about
here's what I remember about each one
but I did one of them from 2003 about a
Montclair Cedar Grove softball game that
my daughter pitched it was a 13 inning
game right and she and one of her best
friends in the world who's from Cedar
Grove and who was a pitcher they met
having pitching lessons and and so they
went at each other like dogs for 13
innings right and it was really one of
the great sports events I've ever seen
in my life but so and you know everybody
says oh keep that crap out of there but
that's really what I have totally gotten
into over the years with the internet
column because they said put some of
yourself in it yeah and so I did I put
that stuff in there I put stuff about my
dogs you know I got two dog obituaries
in there dollars a grin and chive and
off e beer yeah and favourite liquids
it's fun but but the other thing so I've
written over the years I think I wrote
this the other day I've written about
5.5 million words in 29 years at si and
at the mmq b and si.com how many dollars
per word but but so what what I what I
did at the end of trying to figure out
how many words I had written is how many
words I've written like in the mm QB you
know in that Monday column right and
it's about four million
yeah and I'm mind-boggled by that
because that's basically 40 novels damn
I mean and and so I don't know I mean I
and the last week or so it's been such
an emotional time I was me leaving there
because the amount of letters like I got
600 emails last week from people just
basically telling me
stories about you know where they have
read it over the years and some guy in a
subway came up to me a couple of weeks
ago and he says hey good luck to you
I've been I've read you you were
basically my introduction into football
hmm you know I've been reading and
here's a guy in a business suit and a
briefcase gonna work he's whatever
thirty years old yeah I don't know so
it's been kind of an emotional time I'd
say like if you create something and you
build something and then we all know
eventually we don't think about it that
you're gonna have to hand it over
eventually because it you could what
you've the fact that you've created
something that needs to live without you
there shows the foundation that you
built and and I'll tell you this Adam
here's the one thing that I've felt
strongly about over like the last year
so in the old days that Sports
Illustrated I never asked hey I'm gonna
go to San Diego and interview Dan Fouts
well okay just go nobody nobody would
care it was not a big deal but now every
trip you make has got to be approved
everything you do you got to be worrying
about money and so I'd be doing these
things and I just kept thinking to
myself you know I've got there are nine
people average age 30 years old who I
have brought in I've brought in I
brought in actually six of them and
we've gotten three from Sports
Illustrated who helped us do stuff and
who write and these nine people average
age 30 I mean I hate to say it but I'm
like the 800-pound gorilla and as long
as I'm there I'm gonna be doing this I'm
gonna be doing that and I'm gonna be
highlighted when I do this and you know
what they're ready like Kenny Ventus is
red he's been killing it she is great
Robert Klem Co yeah great yeah Connor or
another one of our young writers and E
but noid Albert Breer these are really
really good people at their jobs and if
I stay it just basically keeps them on
the periphery a lot of the times and it
just it really was not fair well the
piece that I saw in mmq be today about
the tables and lighting arrangements
was incredible I'm only kidding when you
could have them QB it's the furniture oh
yeah that is right that's been my number
one question I had for you is well you
know this furniture store still honing
in on cubic feet well this is a very
interesting story for people who don't
know we started the mmq 2013 and we just
wanted it to call we wanted to call it
mm QB and so we there's a furniture
company in North Carolina and I think we
offered them like $25,000 okay for the
name you know to give up mm cubes you
don't melt and they said no and they
asked for $500,000 holy crap and so we
said I said I have a good way to fix
this right just say listen we're gonna
have em MQB and our title but so I mean
I don't know what they have no idea what
they would have would they have paid 30
or 35 but I said don't do it
yeah that's dumb that's a stupid waste
of money right here's what we should do
just put of the in front of it mm-hmm
and that's what we did so the website
was known as the mm QB and my Monday
column was known as the mmm no okay just
mm QB yes and so and so it worked out
fine and it really I guess I don't know
this one of the business guys in our
office said that the guy was really
pissed off in North Carolina because
that was he booked out well people would
would would he'd be getting all of this
traffic maybe getting all these contact
us what the hell where is the football
where is Peter King I don't get it and
he'd have to answer all these emails and
he was also pissed off about it anyway
yeah that to me has been the most
fascinating thing is the first time I
went on I was like man a football only
part like website like I'm so excited I
type it on it was like furniture I love
that he was like I'm gonna cash in but
instead all he got was a ton of contact
us asking where you were I mean who
knows how many he did he got but that's
what I heard man does whatever future
I'm always you know me I always want to
ask you about the past that's a new love
the pile of the past because he is great
history I could sit here and listen to
stories about all that but I also I got
to tell you one story about your father
okay tell me
Big Joe Sims future hall-of-fame big
fighter big Phil I one of the things
that was really interesting is the year
that the Giants won their second Super
Bowl with Parcells yeah against the
bills the crazy game with Hostetler
playing yep so Phil Simms gets hurt on a
Saturday afternoon against the Buffalo
Bills in December right rainy day breaks
his foot or break
yeah breaks his foot and so so he's gone
and Parcells used to have this thing
okay every year where he used to say I
don't want the injured players to be
around and it was so strange because
you'd think to yourself I would want
phil simms in the quarterback meeting
room talking to Jeff Hostetler and and
you know and giving ideas about you know
I just prepared to play the Buffalo
Bills a month ago right and I would like
to have him around just but not not
Parcells Parcells didn't want those guys
around so every night they'd be going
into meetings and I forget what day it
was it might have been Monday might have
been Tuesday might might have been
Wednesday I forget but so I saw Phil and
he goes hey you want to go out to dinner
and so we went out to dinner at burn
steakhouse in Tampa and had a great meal
in everybody classic everybody in the
restaurant is walking by the table and
they're saying Phil Simms as he hurries
his teams in the Super Bowl what does he
that isn't his team involved with
something and I don't think they
understood that Parcells doesn't really
want he thinks the broken foot is gonna
rub off on people you know and so and so
we sat there probably for I know it
wasn't for any story we just sat there
in town center and two and a half hours
and had a really fun time but but there
you got to take the wine tour two
numbers okay cuz it's phenomenal well
they got a good list the thing you know
the one thing I really remember about
and remember about your father that was
really cool as a you know as somebody
covering the team you know and he got
really pissed off at me one time for
quoting him when he thought it was off
the record
long story not that interesting and so
but but I used to love just talking to
him about you know the way the game
really worked and he had a great handle
on the way the game really worked and
you know what was interesting he had
told there was a lot of guys on those
giant teams that didn't really buy into
Parcells because he had different rules
for Lawrence Taylor than anybody his
whole rule his big rule with Lawrence
Taylor is let's keep this guy alive yeah
okay because it's alive he's gonna win
some games for this okay so let's just
keep him alive and forget if he's ten
minutes late yes you know that so yes so
guys like Joe Morris used to get so
angry with the way Parcells treated her
Lawrence Taylor but anyway yeah Phil had
such a great handle on every aspect of
the team why it worked why it didn't
work what happened the relationships and
and everything like that it was he was a
really good quarterback to cover well
football philosophy I mean I think
that's where but Parcells and Belichick
are amazing right it's just they that
philosophical can see the whole game as
a whole and how it all plays into each
other it's interesting with the injury
thing right because I played for Josh
McDaniels and that was my first taste of
that right because he they do New
England does the same thing still to
this day if you're hurt don't come
around you're not gonna help us win on
Sunday and we don't want you in a
meeting room because you're not worried
about the game maybe going off on a
tangent telling a story about has
nothing to do well what do they think
it's like confusing one of the things
that Euston one of the things that used
to enrage Parcells would go to these new
teams and I wrote about it one time in
Dallas his last stop you know when he
went to Dallas yeah the players were
saying they'd go into the into the
trainer's room you know and and they
would they would feel like even maybe it
was like late August or September to be
real hot outside and I know it would
feel fantastic you'd go in there to be
really
cold but after about five minutes
players would say hey man turn this
certain air conditioner off because he
Parcells would have it at 60 degrees
they make it so cold maybe he didn't
want you hanging around in there he
didn't want people in there he did that
stuff for the Giants no I know you know
the one other thing and I only remember
this because I wrote about it today so
you guys might remember this streak but
in 2004 I think it might have been 2003
but 2004 I believe it was the Patriots
were going for their 19th consecutive
regular season win right which would be
an NFL record at the time nobody had
ever won 19 in a row and so that week I
went up there and I was gonna do what
makes the Patriots tick and people were
writing about the Patriots cuz they had
won a couple of Super Bowls but you know
still you know just get on the ground
get in the weeds find out and I get up
there and I'm talking to Mike Vrabel and
he goes well you were able was a
linebacker there at the time he goes you
gotta you gotta you should look into
what person at what person's what
Belichick said to us this week in our
team meeting when he when he met us so
he didn't tell you he said for you to
better yeah because these guys are
really I find out that what that what
Bill Belichick said to his team here
they are they're going for 19 in a row
you know national TV game against Miami
it's gonna be a huge win if they win
celebrations everything like that and he
gets in there and he they had just
beaten Buffalo on Sunday and he goes in
and he stands in front of the team
meeting goes hey if we want to be any
good at all we gotta clean up this
special teams crap that I'm seeing out
there you realize against Buffalo we had
zero return yards we allowed them this
this is and he goes over everything and
the guys in there is one of them said to
me he goes we were worthless pieces of s
because and so and that to me sounded so
familiar because Bill Parcells them all
always had this theory and his theory
was if you've won 18 in a row find
something crappy yeah because you can't
tell them we've arrived
it's October whatever it is we got we
got a lot of work to do
similarly if they've lost four in a row
you've got to tell them that hope is not
lost hey listen I saw some good things
out there here's what we do well and
here's how we're gonna win this Sunday
and that's exactly what Belichick was
doing at the time telling him how bad
they were on special teams so that and
their their gunner their punt team
gunner right a guy named Sean Maher he
fired him that day and I wrote I love I
wrote like that it was like Paulie
walnuts executing a contract hit he had
to sacrifice some money yeah and so he
did and he came in and he and everybody
knew holy crap we've won 18 in a row and
our special teams guy just got whacked
well so I know it's amazing so that see
this is what happens I want to ask him
more questions about history so you go
you go like okay so are they as good as
you like Parcells and Belichick just to
me and I know you know more coaches than
me over a lifetime and being around them
just seemed from my 37 years on the
planet to be the best at the mental
warfare that goes on in football than
anybody I've I've seen or at least
witnessed on the outside Parcells the
reason why and this is the reason why
and look I'm kind of close to Parcells
so people would always say oh you only
want one him in the Hall of Fame because
he's been good to you you're close to
him listen
Bill Parcells coach for teams yeah in
the NFL every team was a piece of crap
when he got there that's right and every
team he took to the player like within
three years it was like wow okay I mean
renko tight is four and twenty eight in
his previous two years
here comes Parcells and all of a sudden
they're competitive but but my only
point about what makes a good coach is
that I think there has to be and nobody
wants to hear this and I think mike
tomlin does this right now better than
anybody except Belichick
you've got to have this ruthlessness
total utter ruthlessness and if you
don't have that you're gonna need it at
some point and if you don't have it it's
over you're not gonna survive and in my
opinion that's one of the things
everybody I think like some some veteran
players have left the Patriots after a
year or two or three or whatever and
they breathe a sigh of relief and they
they have two emotions yeah okay one is
that was an incredible experience and
man I got a ring I never take that away
from me
but with a few of them yeah anyway yeah
oh my god I'm so glad I'm out of yeah I
know yeah because it is so incredibly
mentally demanding I I have said this to
people you know Seth wickersham wrote a
story at ESPN last year saying that
there's all kinds of chemistry problems
Belichick Kraft Brady um it's not long
for this world and I said hold on a
minute Eddie DeBartolo Bill Walsh Joe
Montana the greatest owner coach
quarterback Tina
Trillo yes maybe in history they lasted
10 years Kraft Belichick Brady and that
wasn't perfect people think that was
perfect that was incendiary right that
was incendiary people don't realize that
was not pretty relationship there but
but and I'll tell you one thing about
that in a second please what but I'll
tell you in my opinion this one is the
most amazing one in NFL history yeah I
give craft credit for laying back when
I'm sure there are some times where he
didn't want to lay back credit to Robert
Kraft I give immense credit to Bill
Belichick because he never stopped being
himself ever and I give immense credit
to Tom Brady because he wanted to be
coach Yeah right and every week he could
take the piling on and I think it's
gotten to him a little bit now yeah okay
yeah I think it has I don't know you got
to understand I do
yes I've stated that too like the story
I told you I don't have all the facts I
just have been told the story a few
times and I'm piecing it together
so you're I hear you go ahead but the
but the one thing I will say about this
this incredible time that I mean I'm 60
years old if I live thirty more years I
absolutely guarantee I will never see a
team out the Patriots never and I've
never seen one before the only one close
is and I wasn't alive for the vast
majority of it is the Cleveland Browns
because the Browns in the first ten
years of their history won seven NFL
championships and they lost in the
frigging champ seven pro football teams
yeah it's four years with the it was
with the AFC the first six years they
were in the NFL there they were a team
coming over from this Junior League the
first six years they were in the
championship game every year and the
stories about Paul Brown when I read
them remind me a lot of Belichick
nathless he's got just hated on they
never vouched for him on Belichick
Belichick worships Paul Brown there you
go he worships Paul Brown and and this
is a weird weird thing to say okay
because the more the longer I'm away
from it the more I value it okay 1984
the first year I covered the NFL I
covered the Bengals and we were talking
before about Collinsworth and Esiason
and all the great guys on that team who
were really smart guys but in training
camp that year Wilmington Ohio Central
Ohio you know just every day day after
day after day the be the Sun beating
down on you and and to add a practice
yeah every day I know nine to eleven
right three to five pads I mean I feel
like I used to be for me yeah I mean I
let me back in my day we did to it is
every day in full pads and and in that
year 1984 they had like a five-week
training camp and I will never forget
this Wow Paul Brown was it every
practice and he never missed a minute
and Chris one time you know what I said
to him I said to him III mean I just
you're exhausted after a while to stand
in the Sun for that time okay you ever
had on you have sunscreen but holy crap
you know I always will say I've had two
melanomas in my life
and I attribute those melanomas nuovo
look at this oh yeah I had a big chunk
taken out of my arm I attributed that to
stand on outside and Wilmington Ohio for
four or five hours every day for like
six weeks in the Blazing Sun but I once
said to Paul Brown he was unbelievably
he was a teacher and I would just ask
him why are you doing this why you
didn't yeah and and one time he I said
to him I said Paul I said this ever get
a little tiring for you men every day
we're out here it's this and he goes
young man this is our lifeblood and
that's I'm just telling you if Bill
Belichick Bill Belichick would be like a
little puppy if he could if he could
have lived in the time of Paul Brown he
would have loved Paul Brown they're the
same guy same guy we were talking this
before just to kind of go in Belichick
because the reason I think everyone
talks about Belichick we've never seen a
coach like this he's at the top of the
craft for this long and in this era with
free agency and all the change and
players and social media it's crazy but
how much what does Bill do after this
like I don't know but you know we have a
hearty is he crazy educated me about
something about Belichick that I never
thought of before he was on my podcast
like a year ago and we were talking
about Belichick and his experience with
him and one of the things that I'm
totally paraphrasing this was that you
know like he's the exact same he's got
the same mentality the same level of
stress if you're in some personnel
meeting in May yeah about undrafted free
agent or the week of the sort as he is
the week of the Superbowl it's the same
and so so in other words I've always
thought I mean because you know so I've
been asking people in the last few
months
yeah how much longer for Belichick
that's like you know the people and I
just talked to somebody recently who
knows Bill who just says I mean I think
he's gonna do it at least three more
years
yeah
and because because first of all I don't
think there's anything else other than
maybe you know sailing on the untuk it
that really kind of no pun intended
floats his boat I was gonna say Bruce
Springsteen because everyone that I talk
to it from your dad rate to Doug Flutie
they say the happiest I ever see Bill
Belichick is when he see in the boss and
I could see him just follow and Bruce
Springsteen around the world
Bon Jovi both yeah maybe Bruce Lee I
think it's Bon Jovi your follow John
yeah coach the Philadelphia soul it is
great to have Jon Bon Jovi as an owner
in the NFL it would be wouldn't it be
fantastic question is how would he
discipline the anthem you know cuz now I
was gonna say some guy just bought the
friggin Carolina Panthers for 2.5
billion or whatever to point three I
think and and I just said there aren't a
lot of people in the United States who
have that kind of and the amazing thing
is he paid cash
alright so we got to ask about that
subject a little yeah I mean we're
taping this on the Wednesday the dance
and anthem stuff goes on in its world
releasing this as a Memorial Day yeah so
your point is your first thoughts there
just reading this and I wrote this maybe
about I don't know four or five weeks
ago mm-hmm after the league meetings
[Music]
this I said at the end of the day the
only thing that makes any sense to me is
to tell players that there's potential
discipline if you do anything on the
sidelines and if you don't want to stand
stay in the locker room yeah that's
exactly what they didn't I didn't know
that but it's the only thing that makes
sense to me I'm not defending it because
I am one of these really left-wing guys
who says if a player wants to kneel for
the anthem let him yeah I've told this
story countless times last year I went
to a Mets game at Citi Field and
national anthem comes up I got a hat
here we go and I know
like four or five rows ahead of me
there's a family sitting down and I
don't know that it was a family but it
was four people right and they're just
sitting there and no one was no it's
just the arguments I've made I mean and
so they're just sitting there and the
anthem ends life goes on they play the
game right now look I have experienced
it though you at the Eagles parade these
played the anthem and people had hats on
and I'm talking about other fans like
getting in their face
threatening to fight him it says the
hats are I'm not gonna lie there was a
ten minute period where I was not
excited the Eagles won the Superbowl it
was just like this it punched me in the
face
yeah where it was this debate and you
knew what they were arguing about some
reason for some reason we have allowed
and again since 9/11 i I just I have a
theory about all this but I think since
9/11 we have allowed politics and
patriotism to hijack the nfm almost
everything and and and I'm just gonna
say this I could give two craps about
what is played in the thing in right you
know and in the seventh-inning stretch
when I go to a baseball game god bless
america
yeah I don't I don't care right play it
it doesn't matter one whit to me I'll
always stand for it and when they
introduced the guy who stands on the
dugout who's got an artifice enter and I
mean I just I'm crying yes yeah where's
man I love those guys yeah but the fact
is we've gotten to the point in the
United States where you know at all
public athletic events the only segment
of our society that is celebrated is the
military yeah that's it
how about the teachers in in Arizona
right I in Kentucky who are I I heard
this story from this one this one
teacher stood up in Kentucky graduated
from college got her degree and then
went and spent borrowed more money to
get a masters
and started off at this job teaching
sixth grade somewhere in Kentucky at
29,000 $600 mm-hmm okay now she's been
doing it she's up to like 34,000 or some
whatever the number is but it's not a
lot and I'm just saying to myself these
are the people who I want to celebrate
and I'm fine with celebrating the
military I truly am like I went on a USO
trip in 2008 and I was in all of those
people I I think they're unbelievable I
don't think that they're the only people
and the only segment of our society that
we should celebrate week after week
after week
how about firefighters could we please
bring some firefighters out to stand at
the 50-yard line before a game and
people to celebrate how about some cops
could you have some cops out there how
about the ironworkers who build these
buildings come on yeah I mean it's
really a great point I never thought
about it right I am just tired just
tired of the only segment of society
that we celebrate is the military and I
want to celebrate the military but not
at the exclusion of every other person
who gets up at 5:30 in the morning every
day day after day after day and four
years and gets underpaid at a vastly
important job yeah valid valid valid
points that felt good it did I know I
want to go off with you badly the the
other thing too like so do you think
there's gonna be unintended consequences
here or you know the fact that again
that the NFL owners have done this
without the approval of the players like
what do you would you know what do you
think about that all I can say is no
matter what Roger Goodell would have
done people would have said it was
because Roger Goodell can't win if they
brought in who yeah I feel if they
brought if they brought in I can't even
think of anybody but if they brought in
John Doe a champion of Industry or let's
say I got a good one if they brought in
like George Bush the younger obviously
right they brought in George Bush to be
commissioner and you know he's got a lot
of people who maybe you didn't like him
politically but whatever so he
would make a decision and I whatever the
decision is he would have a honeymoon
period whoever the next Commissioner is
right no matter what Roger Goodell
decided in this case people were gonna
boom that's it that's the way it is in
this in this league right now and I'm
not saying it's the right decision it's
the decision that in my opinion is the
best one of a lot of evils yeah yeah I
got you I think the only thing that's
interesting is by having owners doing
discipline there in my mind they're out
of the protection of Roger Goodell
because Roger Goodell takes all that
heat but now if these individual owners
are charged with disciplining it's gonna
kind of out some of these guys in terms
of where they stand instead of falling
behind Goodell here's where it went
wrong in my opinion I think I think it
went wrong in three different places
number one when Donald Trump said what
he said yep yep the NFL should have come
out instead of just two or three or four
owners saying I am proud of my team I'm
proud of our players they should have
attacked Donald Trump they should have
they should have attacked Donald Trump
and say you have no idea what you're
talking about
blah blah blah blah blah and whatever so
that's that's the one thing right the
second thing is that when this
originally happened and the NFL said we
are gonna meet with this group of
players Malcolm Jenkins and Anquan
Boldin and a lot of really smart
responsible very well-intentioned
players they said okay here's what it
ended up being we're gonna give you a 90
million dollars over the next seven
years and you guys have a committee and
responsibly pick the social causes you
want to support that was a great thing
to do but it was so incredibly naive in
my opinion because what the plate what
the NFL owners thought is we're gonna
give them this they're gonna see this is
beyond goodwill this is incredible
wood they're spending 13 million bucks
every year of money that we're giving
them for to do whatever they want with
their social causes you know and and
they didn't ask for anything in return
well what the NFL should have said is
listen we're gonna do something for you
but in return we
want something mm-hmm D Smith should
have sat in those meetings yeah Eric
Winston should have sat in those
meetings when possible and they should
have said listen here's what we're
willing to do we will support all these
causes will support them financially and
we'll support them with our teams will
do all this but we have to take away
this stuff that is dividing not only our
team in our league but in some ways our
nation Utley we got to stop this so
let's figure out a way to do it whatever
that way is instead the NFL just said
we're giving them 90 million and they
just expected the players to police it
mmm and they didn't know and because
it's not Malcolm Jenkins job to tell her
agreed stand up exactly I mean it has to
be done collectively man I know well I
have a million more topics but we've
literally gone more than like twice as
much as we thought we would gosh what
are we gonna do now then uh what are we
gonna do me out yeah yeah I don't know
what I think Blake bortles no Peter that
was amazing man I appreciate it was fun
yeah we always leach reports office it's
beautiful you know I hate to do it but
yeah I go I gotta go do something 3:30
with you guys thank you do we know the
Twitter handle do we know okay so Peter
King me I'll coming soon
NBC Ricky Camacho and pro football talk
so you do them working right yeah well
Chris is gonna do it a lot more than I
am I don't want to get up yeah the part
of this thing is living a sane life not
getting up at 6 o'clock to go do ray
take your life back that if you want to
see a flustered Florio know what days
Peters off Florio doesn't I with me
shows need no respect but you he's like
he's like a head coach with man this is
a star player in his front
do them Parcells of the lawrence taylor
yeah yeah you are lawrence taylor now
it's a welcome full circle I want to say
thank you for coming in I wanna say
thank you for the twenty nine years and
the countless stories and the five point
five million words yeah it's been
awesome thanks for always being a
stand-up guy thanks to you guys Sims and
Lefko fans for everything that you do as
always hit us up on social at Sims and
left go subscribe and as well as leave a
comment on iTunes we're nearing a
thousand five star reviews which is
amazing you guys are great but Peter you
know an RV with John Madden awesome
thank you man Larry